dozier cats taking her own advice
[Music]
and proving she's got nothing to lose as
she shoots her shot with stranger things
breakout star joseph quinn
this year
it's my year
i can feel it
yeah so doja attempted to get joseph's
attention by way of his co-star noah
schnapp sliding into will byers dms for
a setup can i
show you something and noah flipped it
all upside down by exposing what went
down in those dms on tick-tock here's
doja's first message noah can you tell
joseph to hit me up wait no does he have
a girlfriend
that's when noah brushed off becoming a
matchmaker by telling the singer to
slide on over to joseph's dms herself
that's a great idea
then when doges said she couldn't find
joseph's profiles noah came through with
the hookup aka a direct link to his page
it was just a lot of fun to play around
this whole would-be love affair actually
started over on twitter where doja
professed her feelings for joseph aka
eddie munson after watching volume one
of stranger things season four doja
called the actor quote fine ash
and that caused fandoms to collide doges
kittens and demogorgon devotees aligned
to start shipping the stars i love that
so when a fan account called on doja to
check out a fine pic of joseph she came
through with another thirsty comment
now her reply has since been deleted but
screenshots show doges saying joseph's
looks are
incriminal and that brings us to doge's
dms with noah which is kind of where the
story ends for now we don't know if a
love match has been made yet but we do
know doja clicked the follow button on
joseph's profile that's the only thing i
can tell you we'll have to see what doja
shares from here on out she's kept
pretty private when it comes to her
personal life last year during a
sit-down with apple music she made it
clear she likes to keep her love life
out of the spotlight would you ever have
a public relationship again
um no
absolutely how are you going now so
you're becoming
like you are a and if she hasn't gotten
a reply from joseph yet she can always
spend time with him by re-binging season
four
though that might not be the most fun
thing since eddie spoiler alert dies
you're gonna have to look after those
little sheep for me okay no you're gonna
do that yourself
yeah it feels like the perfect crescendo
for this kind of this crazy sequence and
yeah i just think the inventiveness to
kind of come up with that and
the bravery to put it in is kind of it's
um yeah well done duff of others but hey
no more stranger things could mean more
free time for you know dating
as for joseph he's yet to comment or
react to joja's obvious interest
though dojo might have a little
competition in that department because
joseph admits the outpouring of love and
support has been a little overwhelming
it's so lovely like the
the devotion that the fans have for this
show and kind of
um how they've found space in their
heart for a new character
um eddie is just so it's heartwarming
and um yeah
i don't know what to say about it it's
really they've been so gracious and
welcoming
it's lovely
[Applause]
you